hey guys how's it going so some of you
might have already been quite aware of
this but there are new emojis on iOS I
think there's 150 to be exact I'm
excited because I love emojis I
basically have full conversations in
emojis and you know even have to say a
word so I'm gonna go through a few of
the new ones that I can spot right off
hand a few of my favorites one of my
favorites is the upside down smiley face
like it's cool a cool summer a little
money face this little nerdy gap is a
little teeth hanging out this little guy
this little guy zip it not feeling so
hot this guy this little head bandaged
up this one's definitely new it's like a
and the jazz hands oh I can't believe it
there's a middle finger so inappropriate
so inappropriate is the white sneaker
new channel the white sneaker okay so
you don't think it's new this is a hat a
lion nice oh that's that's the rabbit
lion sleeps tonight a unicorn
I love the unicorn he's super cool gonna
put a bunch of those a spider the
scorpion crab puffer fish
I remember seeing him a turkey a duh a
squirrel there's yeah there's an
elephant before will delete you
sunflower
spiderweb lab you walking in a spiderweb
oh this struggle that's not new a
shooting star
look at all these new weather's really
get in the weather I'll turn what is
this what look at this
Boop the drop is not new a chili pepper
what is that a cantaloupe like at some
point you're not gonna ever need words
cheese the hotdog new hey hey you over
there hot dog is the hot dog new maybe a
taco a burrito
this is great the popcorn oh definitely
a champagne James I have a cold I'm
congested Bob all what's that paddle
but the wiffleball chalky I don't know
what's worth the put of supporters that
tells us oh shoot
I lost my sports new golf one lifted
that's me that's maybe lying bassant
what's that ten that's not new is it
these medals are new I think the one
medal is that's new getting new cars
that's new what the hell is that what is
that motor motor motor bike bicycle way
to look at this my plane just took off
my plane just weird with women that's
new that's new with that a satellite guy
this is just I'd have a great time thank
you sir no thank you some of those I'm
not a hundred percent sure Oh a new
mouse these little churches are all new
the keyboard already posted that what is
that it's a printer got it a laptop now
if you guys had any favorites yeah like
what's your what's your favorites so
movie this what's that what are you new
trash can a candle think that's a new
flashlight oh wow look at these shields
just some more weaponry we really get
turned up at a guy like a toe tag look
at all these things okay now on board
there's too many how am I ever going to
be able to find these things when I need
to send them to my friends I'm sure some
of these are nobody never use any of
those these are no that's no that's no
sure some of these flags are new so
those are some of the new emojis that I
first just recognized right off the bat
let me know if you guys have a new
favorite emoji what do I think of emojis
anyway do you think that people should
not use them as conversations but what
if it's a well thought out emoji story I
don't know anyway I'll see you guys
later
that's all of that peace
you